- Guys, don't judge him.
He's happy with who he is.
We just legalized gay marriage
in this country.
Don't take a step back
on dog homosexuality.
[dark electronic music]
♪
Welcome to
"This Is Not Happening."
I'm your host, Ari Shaffir.
And today the topic is crime.
[cheers and applause]
Please help me welcome
the host
of the "Skeptic Tank" podcast,
Ari Shaffir.
[cheers and applause]
Here's the deal:
I moved to New York
not too long ago,
a few years ago.
And it's great.
It's a lot of fun.
People are like,
"Which one do you like better?"
I'm like,
"They're fuckin' both--
they're both great;
they're both great."
There's this war going on
between LA and New York,
and I don't understand it.
Like, "Which one's better?
Which one's better?"
"New York sucks."
"LA sucks."
I'm like,
"Fuckin' Kansas City sucks."
[laughter]
Why are you trying
to hurt each other?
It's like, who's better,
Kobe Bryant or Kevin Durant?
Well, in terms of non-rape,
I guess it would be
Kevin Durant.
[laughter]
But--that's right,
I hate the Lakers.
[laughter]
People are like,
"Why won't you forget it?"
I'll never forget it.
Anyway, that's all sidetrack.
When I really like LA better
is in the winter.
So what I do is,
I find some comedian
to switch apartments with
for the winter.
I come here; they go there.
I ask them usually in June.
They look at the weather report,
and they're like,
"Yeah, New York seems fine."
[laughter]
And then, like,
January rolls around.
They're like,
"You double-crossed me!"
And I'm like, "I can't hear you
over the sunshine."
[laughter]
So I switched apartments
with my friend Benji Aflalo.
And he double-crossed me too,
because when I got
to his apartment,
he was like, "Oh, by the way,
I got a dog.
You got to take care of it.
Bye."
[laughter]
And then he left.
This dog bit me for, like,
the first week I was there too.
I was like,
"Why is your dog biting me?"
He was--he stayed for,
like, three days.
We stayed, like, together.
And then he left.
But I was like,
"Why is your dog biting me?"
He's like, "Well, you know,
dogs can smell fear."
[laughter]
And I was like, "Yeah,
but why is he biting me?"
He's like, "Well, you know,
when they smell fear"--
I've never understood
that logic of, like,
just 'cause you know
I'm scared of you, dog,
why is physical violence
your answer to that?
That's asshole logic.
Like, how about
you know I'm scared.
Walk slowly
when I'm in the room.
[laughter]
Set me at ease.
Don't be like, "Scared?
Fuckin' scared?"
Like, "Yes,
please stop doing that,
and I won't be
as frightened of you."
[laughter]
It was fun taking care
of this dog too, though.
I fell in love with him.
I love this dog.
'Cause a lot of you
don't understand.
My thought was,
"I'll take him on walks;
I'll meet chicks,"
you know.
Like, "Oh, you got a dog.
I got a dog."
[mumbling]
You know.
That's a "one thing leads
to another" situation.
[laughter]
I love this dog.
Here's my question
about dogs, by the way.
They say they're supposed
to have
a really good sense of smell.
We've heard that
since we were little.
Dogs--really good
sense of smell.
Okay, well then how come,
when they're smelling
another dog's asshole,
do they have to be inside
that dog's asshole
in order to make out
what it is?
'Cause that doesn't seem like
a very good sense of smell
at all.
[laughter]
I have guy friends
who if they haven't showered
for, like, a day and a half,
I can smell their assholes...
[laughter]
From, like, six feet away
through clothing.
I'm like, "It was one
of you guys.
I don't know which one, but I
can clearly smell asshole."
I don't have to treat it
like a 40-year-old wine
where I'm like,
"Hold on, let me--
let me really get in there."
[mumbles]
[inhales deeply]
[laughter]
"Yup, that's an asshole,
all right.
Story checks out."
[laughter]
"Same place as the others."
Anyway, this dog,
he was so cool.
Who has dogs here, anybody?
[people cheer]
You guys got a dog.
Your dog do any tricks?
- Sleeps a lot.
- Sleeps a lot?
That's not really a trick.
That's depression.
[laughter]
You want your dogs
to do tricks.
Nothing crazy,
nothing crazy.
All I wanted to teach
this dog was to fetch.
That was my goal.
It was, like,
nine-, ten-month-old dog,
and I'm like, "I can still
teach it," you know?
Fetch: basic shit.
Nothing crazy.
Some people do that trick
where you put
a treat on the dog's nose
and they got to fuckin'
sit there and not eat it,
just balancing it,
and then you're like,
"Okay, go,"
and then they eat it.
That's fuckin' slave shit.
Don't do that to your dog.
That's part of your family.
That's unnecessary.
Oh, this thing that you love--
here, it's right
next to your face
where you can smell it.
Don't eat it.
[laughter]
I just wanted
this dog to fetch.
That's all I wanted him
to do: fetch.
Easiest shit
in the world, right?
And I tried--I tried
to teach him how to fetch.
It was so hard, but I tried.
I watched YouTube videos
on how to train a dog to--
I watched 30 seconds
of one YouTube video
on how to train
a dog to fetch.
I bought the crinkly
kind of toy.
I bought those little,
tiny tennis balls
so he can get his fucking
tiny Chihuahua mouth around it.
[laughter]
Nothing worked.
He had no interest in fetching.
You know what he loved?
[people murmuring]
Nope, none of you guys got it.
You're never gonna get it.
You're not even
on the right path.
Semen, semen.
He loved semen.
[laughter]
I'm not done there.
I'm not gonna just leave it
out there like that
and be like, "All right,
next story."
There's more to it.
I'm gonna explain it.
I came home one day,
and in his dog bed,
he had all these tissue papers.
And he was, like, fucking
biting these tissue papers
and, like, eating them.
And I was like,
"Benji, why is your dog
biting all these tissue papers?"
And he goes, "Oh, motherfucker.
"He's been in my room again.
"Yeah, he goes in there
and treasure hunts
for jizz rags."
[laughter]
"And he brings them
back to his bed
"like a job well done.
He gets to enjoy his spoils."
He loves semen.
I don't care.
I'm not gonna judge him.
Let him be happy
with who he is.
He knows what he loves.
I'll just lock my door,
that's all.
I kept the door closed,
and I wouldn't let him
in my room.
But once, I went
to the bathroom,
and when I came back,
he had one of my
inside-out socks
in his bed.
Smart dog.
[laughter]
Fine, whatever.
I don't care.
All I want
is to be a dog trainer,
and I tried everything
to get this dog to fetch.
I tried everything.
I bought him a little fetch toy.
It's, like, a rubber
hollow thing.
You put a treat on the inside,
and then you let him smell it,
and he wags his tail, all happy.
And then I'd throw it;
he would just look at it...
[laughter]
And then look back at me
like, "You know
you're gonna go get that."
[laughter]
I'd be like, "Come on, come on."
And then I'd be like,
"See, don't you"--
I'm like,
"You're fucking training me."
[laughter]
No interest in fetching.
Anyway, towards the end
of the winter,
I was having sex with a woman
and used a condom for once...
[laughter]
And, uh--
Feels great to use a condom.
I feel like I'm not
part of the problem.
[laughter]
Anyway, I finished,
and I went to the bathroom
to throw out the condom,
you know,
in the trash can
in the bathroom.
And when I opened the door,
the dog,
he got all excited
to see me, you know,
'cause I was in the bedroom
killing it
for, like, eight hours.
[laughter]
Could've been ten minutes.
I don't know.
Could've been ten.
Dogs can't tell time.
To him, it was, like, a day.
It didn't matter.
Dogs can't tell time.
[laughter]
And, uh, I saw him.
I was like, "Oh, hey, buddy,
excited to see me?"
But he wasn't looking at me.
He was looking at my hand
with the condom in it.
And I was like, "What are--
No."
[laughter]
And to test it,
I went like that,
and then he goes, like--
like, up on two legs.
You know when they do
that thing?
I'm like, "You fucking slut."
[laughter]
To him, it was like
a glass of milk.
Guys, don't judge him.
He's happy with who he is.
We just legalized gay marriage
in this country.
Don't take a step back
on dog homosexuality.
[laughter]
I don't care.
He loves semen.
Let him be into what he's into.
That's what he likes.
That's what he wants.
But what I want
is to be a dog trainer.
[laughter]
So I got
that little fetch toy...
[laughter]
And I put--
uh-huh, yup, yup.
Mm-hmm, yup, yup.
You're right.
You're right too.
That's right, mm-hmm.
Yup, yup.
That's right.
You know what's gonna happen.
Mm-hmm, yup, yup.
That's right.
Mm-hmm, yup.
[laughter]
I put it down,
and then I took the condom,
and I turned it over,
and I just kind of, like...
[laughter and groans]
Emptied it...
[laughter]
Onto this fetch toy.
And then I let him smell it,
and he loved it.
[laughter]
He was like,
"Om, nom, nom."
He couldn't get enough of it.
I'd take it, and I'd throw it,
and he'd fuckin' run after it.
I'd take it out again
and throw it.
He was so excited--
you know the thing they do
where they can't even
get traction,
where they're just like...
this for a while,
and then it starts catching in?
He would do that,
like burning rubber.
[laughter]
I jizzed on everything
after that, you guys.
The tennis ball,
the crinkly toy...
[laughter]
All of it.
Yeah, my methods
are a little bit unorthodox.
[laughter]
I'm a lot like House.
But there's only one thing
that's important there,
and that is that
I am a dog trainer.
[laughter]
[cheers and applause]